drug traffickers aspect triptis got
notorious he is isolated 23 hours a day in
a seven square meter cell
this is due to the fact that a
person who is so accused of crimes
and he is also known to be in danger of
course also subject
to being attacked by fellow inmates  become
christian baby came a 64 year old and
an informant quality knows firmer
footing lost she stayed in shape and rosi
criminal police service information
should it be the same
person i consider him a very
bad witness a person who
has spent his whole life with it
to
gain personal benefit only through deception is
basically not a particularly
reliable witness christian beeck l in
dreihausen george tim baxter says no
public azzurra thick path activity
you just have to pee in a corner often enough
so that it stinks there that will
definitely be for christian  b be the case
so I don't think so  that he will once again
lead a normal life so that he
can go somewhere unrecognized and he will not
be exposed to any kind of hostility
think christian do you have the code
madelin confess
no of course he is not an innocent lamb
has made many mistakes in his
past only that  Doesn't mean
he
shouldn't be hastily convicted of other things